today on the matt walsh show there's a
common thread linking the mass shooting
in texas to so many other mass shootings
and much of the crime and violence in
our society that is fatherlessness this
is the aspect of the problem the media
doesn't want to talk about but we will
today also reports now suggest that the
cops on the scene at the shooting took
upwards of 90 minutes to neutralize the
shooter how could that have happened and
does this disprove the good guy with a
gun concept as the left is claiming of
course not i'll explain plus barack
obama puts out what may be the worst
tweet of the decade beto makes an ass of
himself once again evergreen headline
there another teacher records herself
grooming her students and our daily
cancellation is it true that we're the
only country where these kinds of mass
shootings happen we'll deal with that
false narrative today and much more on
the matt walsh show
[Music]
it's time parents time to finally cross
off one of the most important things on
your to-do list life insurance fabric
makes getting a great life um term life
insurance policy for your family quick
easy and surprisingly affordable fabric
was built specifically for parents to
help you manage your family's financial
future like a parenting pro stress free
fabrics new lower prices mean
significant savings over other providers
with great policies like a million
dollars in coverage for less than a
dollar a day everything is on your
schedule with uh fabric because it's all
online less than 10 minutes to apply and
you could be offered coverage instantly
with no health exam required then just
personalize your quote to fit your
family's needs it's as simple as that
with fabrics online hub it's easy to
track your family finances all in one
place get affordable life insurance
set up your kids college savings plan
and even establish a rainy day savings
fund planning for the future has never
been easier there's no risk to apply
today fabric has a 30-day money-back
guarantee and you can cancel at any time
protect your family with term life
insurance now in just 10 minutes apply
today at
meetfabric.comwalsh that's
meetfabric.com walsh to start protecting
your family today m-e-e-t fabric.com
welsh fabric insurance agency policies
issued by vantislife not available in
new york and montana price is subject to
underwriting and health questions
details are emerging as the media likes
to put it about the mass shooter who
slaughtered 21 people including 19
children at an elementary school in
texas
you don't need to read these details
because they're entirely predictable in
fact i did predict them i accurately
predicted his whole life story basically
yesterday on this show before having
read these reports not because i'm
nostradamus these are you know there are
certain things we all
always assume about these shooters and
we're almost always right all of us the
patterns are so clear that even the the
least perceptive among us can't help but
notice them
even if some of those in the least
perceptive group including much of the
news media which certainly falls into
that group would prefer that we don't
notice them
according to his family and those who
knew him were told that the shooter was
a loner didn't have many friends spent
uh it would seem most of his time alone
online
staring at various screens
had a history of bizarre disturbing
behavior he once came to school with
self-inflicted cuts all over his face
and of course
the most inevitable detail of all
he did not have a father in the home
his home life was not stable he lived
apparently with his mom in fact um some
of the information about his personal
life is coming from the mother's
boyfriend not the shooter's father
not much is known about the father
except that he lives somewhere else in
the neighborhood and he has a criminal
record
so does the mother another revelation
that surprises nobody
shortly before the shooting he moved out
of his mom's house cops were called
there's all kinds of domestic things
going on moves in with his grandmother
and his grandmother was the first person
he shot on the day of his bloody rampage
unstable home life
no father in the home
mass shooter
this is not a unique combination
a huge and disproportionate number of
mass shooters come from fatherless homes
now it's not an airtight rule of course
sometimes boys raised in homes with both
a mom and a dad
uh will still lash out in the most
violent ways imaginable as was the case
i believe with the shooter in buffalo i
think he had both a mother and father in
the home but those are really the
exceptions and even in those cases the
father may have been present physically
that doesn't mean he was present in any
of the ways that really matter now
there's no way to really know how many
mass shooters come from homes with
fathers who were present
physically and
actively invested in their children's
lives because that's not the same thing
necessarily now you can't quantify that
it doesn't lend itself to bar graphs but
there's every reason to assume that the
number is very small if not zero
i mean the number of mass shooters who
are coming from homes where the father
is there and actively engaged and
invested in his in his children's lives
what's the number how many how many
homes like that have produced a mass
shooter
i think we have every reason to assume
that it's very very small
and the problem runs much deeper mass
shooting statistics are just the tip of
the iceberg of course over 60 percent of
youth suicides are from
fatherless homes over 80 percent of
youths in prison are from fatherless
homes 70 of high school dropouts are
from fatherless homes 70 of kids and
drug abuse treatment centers are from
fatherless homes
almost all of the gun violence in our
cities almost all of it is committed by
young males who are raised without
fathers and we know that because the
fatherless home rate in those
communities often runs upwards of 80
percent or higher
the fatherless home epidemic is a
verified
legitimate national emergency and should
be treated as such
now the fatherless factor is just one
part of the equation right
the other part is that nearly all of the
kids who fall into these statistics are
boys
you know pretty much every mass shooter
in american history with rare exception
has been a male
93 of the inmates in federal prison are
men 90 of murders are committed by men
the majority of rapists and child
molesters are male again not all but the
majority men are three more three three
times more likely to kill themselves
much more likely to drop out of school
much more likely to end up homeless much
more likely to end up abusing drugs
now our culture looks at the picture as
i painted it and
well they conclude that masculinity is
toxic right a blight on the earth
and the culture then proceeds to try to
fix the the boy problem the way you fix
like a dog
it sees that boys are inclined to be
aggressive so the culture wants to force
them to be mild
it sees that boys are likely to take
dangerous risks so it encourages boys to
take no risks at all it sees that boys
are are wild
you know so it tames them
it sees that boys are boys and so it
tries to turn them into girls literally
and that strategy has been a disaster
as we work to try to sort of neuter and
feminize boys all of the problems listed
above have only gotten worse
so what can we do about it
the solution brings us back to the
beginning fathers
boys need to be taught how to be boys
and they need fathers to teach them that
a mother can't really teach her son how
to be a man any more than i can teach my
daughter how to be a woman
i can teach her how a woman ought to be
treated and that's a very important
lesson that fathers can provide to their
daughters
but i can't shape her in her femininity
the way that my wife can
likewise my wife cannot form and harness
our son's masculinity the way that i can
and neither can we of course rely on tv
or pop culture or the schools
media the government any of those
institutions to do the job
they're not going to mold my son they're
just going to simply uh obliterate him
or at best they're going to give him
this kind of confused
cartoon version of what a man is which
is why when you look around
at society you see a bunch of cartoon
men walking around
not so much masculine as like imitating
what they think masculinity is supposed
to be
so everywhere a boy turns if he can't
turn to his father he will find powerful
forces trying to drag him into
self-loathing despair confusion
now you know you hear from feminists all
the time to say that masculinity is
fragile
and they're sort of right actually
because a boy's identity is in a way a
fragile thing the same is true of girls
you know children are in a lot of ways
fragile
um we often hear our kids are very
resilient and and in certain respects
they are like a kid can
take a tumble from six feet high and uh
just get up and hop up and be perfectly
fine whereas you know for me i would be
laying in bed for the next five and a
half weeks
but emotionally and psychologically
they're not resilient actually
it's just that a lot of times the harm
that's done to them you can't see it
manifest right away so you assume that
they're fine but they're not
children need to be
formed in their identity they need to be
protected
or they'll be consumed by all these evil
forces out there
so a boy needs someone his father namely
to show him
what to do how to maneuver in the world
how to harness his masculine energy how
to be a boy how to be a man
or else he'll figure it out on his own
finding no help anywhere else and the
result may literally kill him
and dozens more perhaps
now
it should be clear to anybody listening
if they're listening honestly
so it's not going to count like media
matters
but if you're listening honestly it
should be clear the point here
is not to make excuses for young men who
do horrible things
okay
the point is to figure out how to
produce fewer young men who do horrible
things
that should be our objective
and if we all agree that more young men
these days seem to be doing horrible
things that that would mean that this is
not inevitable it doesn't need to be
this way something can be done to
reverse the trend
and it's and it's got to go way beyond
changing
uh you know it it goes way beyond
anything that like a simple policy can
can fix
and it's got nothing to do with gun
control
because even if we were to pretend that
you could
uh make a change to gun control laws
that would actually prevent
every potentially bad person from
getting their hands on a gun
which you can't but i'm just saying for
the sake of argument hypothetically if
you could
make a change and so it's gonna make it
that all these uh all these horrible
young men can't get their hands on guns
okay well we still have all these
horrible people though don't we
that's still a big problem
and there's still a danger
to society
like even if you were able to remove
one of the potential
tools they could use to inflict damage
one of the potential weapons can't
remove them all
and we're still stuck in a society with
these kinds of people so the the real
question is how to produce fewer of them
not how to produce fewer men or fewer
boys generally
but fewer of these types of people
and this is what we can do
have fathers in the home
raising their sons we can and should do
other things too but it should start
with getting fathers back in the home
and keeping them there
fathers and mothers both play an
integral role in the spiritual and
emotional formation of a child you take
one or both away
and there's a chance that the child
becomes emotionally and spiritually
deformed not just hands a very good
chance
this is a very simple formula there's no
disputing it just ignoring it
and oftentimes in our society we do
choose to ignore and i think for a few
reasons for one thing
the left-wing cultural narrative
requires us to deny the distinction
between men and women which means
denying the distinction between mothers
and fathers
according to progressivism the nuclear
biological family is but one type of
arrangement one
variant which is equal
in every way to families with one mom or
two moms or three dads or whatever
and none can be judged more ideal than
the others even though progressives
obsess over
organic milk and free-range chickens
they pretend that the natural organic
family the family as it was meant to be
as it naturally is is in no way superior
to the modified versions
um but to connect violence to broken
homes is to admit
that kids benefit from having mom and
dad in the same house which is why they
don't want to admit that
progressives can make no such a mission
so they continue blaming
bad things on inanimate objects rather
than fatherlessness and divorce
but for another thing beyond ideology i
think we ignore the family's role in all
this because it hits
literally too close to home for a lot of
us
some single mothers bizarrely see a
discussion about fatherhood as an attack
on them for example
i mean anytime this conversation comes
up you'll often hear from single mothers
saying what are you saying that i
thought
my son's automatically become a mass
shooter no that's not what we're saying
what we're saying is that you're the
situation you're in
and it might not be your fault
if you're a single mother it might it
might also be your fault it might
partially be your fault a lot of times
it's it's a you know 50 50 kind of
situation
but every situation is different
there's plenty of single mothers it's
not their fault
the father walked out on them not their
fault
father died father's in prison not your
fault
yet the point is it's not an ideal
situation like you would i hope admit
that it'd be better
if there was an active involved good
father in the home
you'd think we could all admit that but
apparently we can't
people don't like talking about the
problems with the way modern families
are often structured because often it
means that they're looking critically at
their own family structure
and nobody wants to do that
but no matter how no matter how much we
ignore it
the recipe remains the same
okay
you start with a boy
take away his father
or his father takes himself out of the
equation this is often the case
uh you sit him in front of a screen all
day
you feed him an endless stream of
content
you feed him porn
give him no moral formation no guidance
no companionship
uh no role models
no mentorship
and then when he starts acting weird you
give him drugs
keep him isolated
add a few years into it and that's how
you make a school shooter
that's how you make so many terrible
things
we have to understand this recipe
because if we understand it and
acknowledge it and confront it
then we will know the solution
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well you know i don't do uh birthday
shout outs on this show but i'll make an
exception for my own kids the twins who
turned nine today uh not that they
listened to this show i would never
allow that of course i'm not crazy but
they turned nine
and um so we have we have nine year olds
somehow and it's always a it's a weird
thing as a parent
um you know as your kids kind of grow
older and all parents talk about how it
goes so fast
you know it's this interesting dynamic
where
the years fly by but but sometimes you
know the days can kind of drag on a day
feels like a million years but the year
feels like a day that's kind of what it
feels like to be a parent
and i think one of the reasons for that
is that you you always sort of
feel like a new parent you know you
always have
in the back of your mind this
realization that you have no idea what
you're doing
you're just kind of making it up as you
go and that's and that's every parent
and i didn't realize that until i became
a parent and it's very it's like you
because when you're a kid you look at
your parents and you think well they got
it all figured out they know what
they're doing then you become a parent
you realize oh they were just they
didn't they had no idea
and that's because as kids age it always
introduces new phases of parenting and
those new phases have their own
challenges so you're always kind of a
rookie because you're going into the new
phase you've never been here before and
so you're it's almost starting from
scratch
and even after you feel like you've
mastered a particular phase or stage of
parenting or age of child right
then if you have more kids the next kid
will introduce some new wrinkle
like you feel like you'll have you've
had a few kids you've had so you've had
a few three-year-olds and you think well
i got the three-year-old thing down i
got that then you have another kid and
then she starts doing stuff that the
other three-year-old didn't do and and
you're like well hang on a second this
isn't how this is supposed to work
so that's the way it goes anyway uh so
it's their birthday today happy birthday
it's kind of a landmark occasion
actually because um
this is the first birthday where the
twins have wanted their own parties
uh and my response to that was
well too bad just like you have the same
birthday it's gonna be the same party
you'll share that my mom my uh but then
i i keep hearing how they have to have
their own identities and everything so
um so we give them their own parties and
uh which means that you know that
my son has a party my daughter has a
party and then but none of the parties
are actually on the actual birthday so
then it's like really three three
birthdays we're doing for all the kids
my wife's in heaven because
birthdays parties presents that's her
love language she loves it
um
all right
well i want to want to go to this
and there's still a lot i'm almost
hesitant
to read it because there's still so much
we don't know and there's a whole lot of
questions but
you know it's it's important the
questions have to be asked which is why
i think it's it's worth looking at this
story so this is what we're being told
going back to the
tragic situation down in texas this from
the daily mail it says
frantic parents of the children murdered
in their texas school screamed at law
enforcement officers to enter the school
and discuss storming the building
to rescue their kids
um harrowing footage shows and there's
some of the footage that's circulating
online
i'm not going to play it because it's
not even it's not it's really not clear
especially if you're just listening to
audio what exactly is happening
in the footage but the claim anyway is
that this was footage
taken
while the shooting was happening
and you can see
in the footage a whole bunch of police
officers heavily armed just kind of like
standing there
and what they're doing is just stopping
the parents from going into school
and they don't appear to be doing much
of anything else
um
it says it emerged that the gunman was
only stopped when authorities obtained a
key to open the classroom door
they couldn't break the door now
new footage shows the chaotic crowd
outside the school as heavily armed
sheriffs and law enforcement stand guard
and hold them back in one case seemingly
wrestling a panic-stricken woman to the
ground and pinning her down
what are you doing get inside the
building one person could be heard
screaming
another woman could be heard saying
they're trapped inside as howls of pain
anguish rang out in the background
it was unclear at what time the footage
was shot it also emerged wednesday that
customs of border patrol agents who
rushed the scene had to grab a key from
school staff to open the door of the
classroom where the bloodbath took place
so here's the timeline according to this
daily mail article according to the
reports
the first 911 call was received at 11 32
a.m on tuesday
this is the 9-1-1 call saying
when when they saw
the guy
crash his car get out with a rifle and
make his way into the door they got they
got a 911 call okay
the gunman was not killed until 1pm
an hour and a half later
after a border patrol agent was given a
key to the door
i've seen other reports that it was like
40 minutes 40 minutes to an hour
but whether we're talking about an hour
an hour and a half
it's just it's unthinkable
and and again a lot of questions
already
the picture that we're getting here is
quite different from the picture that
first emerged and that's often the case
um as this as you know as kind of the
fog parts a little bit things become a
little bit clearer and you start and
there's certain details that come out
that you didn't know initially and that
might happen here that clarifies some of
this but right now as the story stands
we're looking at potentially 90 minutes
between 911 call there's somebody with a
rifle going into elementary school and
then he's not shot dead for an hour and
a half half later and it's not because
the elementary school is out in the
middle of nowhere and it took an hour
and a half to get there somehow i don't
know where elementary school would have
to be located for that to be the case
but they were there on the scene
according to these reports though
including including from parents who
were there and are speaking out they
didn't go in the building
they had to wait for a key
you don't have a way to break the door
down
how
what could this this scumbag have done
to barricade that door that you had no
way of opening it
and did the classroom have windows i
guess we don't know that but
if it had windows then why don't you
break in the windows
one thing that we're hearing from some
people especially on social media that
are trying to
make excuses
it seems to me they're saying well
protocol they'll wait for backup
well no it's actually not protocol
see this was the situation in columbine
where you had cops waiting for backup
and ever since then the protocol has
been you don't wait for backup you go in
because there are kids being killed
right now now it's one thing if it's a
hostage situation okay if if if no shot
has been fired and there's a a guy
taking kids hostage in a classroom
well now it's a more delicate situation
and you might not just rush in there
because then you might get the kids
killed and that's when you get into the
hostage negotiation but if they're if
he's just executing everybody in the
room
then you rush in there's nothing to
think about
and that does not appear to be what
happened here and this excuse of they
had to wait for a key it's just
mind-boggling
now i'm not going to pretend to be an
expert on law enforcement tactics or the
sort of
uh resources they have at their disposal
but i'm pretty sure
that cops have ways of breaking doors
down
pretty sure they do
so that doesn't make any sense to me at
all
and and uh by the way
i understand it's easy for me to say
right i'm sitting here very comfortably
and i'm not the one who has to charge in
there into gunfire and
you know there's a there's a
a not insignificant chance of getting
shot and killed so that's so it's easy
for me to say true but it's still it's
still correct that this is your job and
if you're a police officer
and you're too afraid
to charge it potentially into gunfire in
a situation like this then
get off of the force and get a different
job because this is your job
okay it's just like if there's a uh
you know
a plane crash
where things go wrong on the plane and
the the pilot just panics
and and freezes up and then the plane
crashes and kills everybody
yeah it's easy for me to say well that
pilot this is on the pilot he should
have he should have done his job yes
he's but i'm not a pilot that's not the
job that i'm taking on
you take on this responsibility
uh when you decide you want to become a
pilot
well if you're a police officer this is
this is the responsibility you assume
it's to handle situations like this
and i think this is pretty fair if you
don't want to do it then don't have the
job let someone who is willing to take
that risk take that job
and i just can't like
wouldn't every
you don't even need to be a hero it
would seem to me it's just your your
it's almost like a biological impulse
okay it's one thing if there's some kind
of shooting going on back and forth at a
at a drug house or on a street corner
between drug dealers
and you're a little bit more hesitant to
get involved there
but
when when little kids are being executed
wouldn't every fiber of your being just
compel you to go in there
uh
there are a lot of questions being
raised here that need to be answered
and um
you know immediately after this we heard
about one of the one of the first things
we heard from
the local officials and for the governor
is that the first responders were heroic
and we should you know be thankful to
the heroic first responders
well somebody did eventually go in there
and kill this guy
and and uh that person i don't know you
know if
one of the reports that we're hearing is
that somebody showed up i think it was
what they're saying as a border patrol
agent and he just went in and and he
took care of it and if that's what
happened then yeah that guy's a hero
but you're not necessarily a hero just
because you're on the scene there's
nothing heroic about having the job and
showing up
if you're there sitting outside because
you're too afraid to go in then that's
not heroic
so maybe we should hold off on just
declaring everybody that was there a
hero
okay because it there's a chance here
that um some of the people were were
quite the opposite of heroic
and need to be fired for it at a minimum
i just can't
as i keep saying there could be other
details that come out but 90 minutes
it's impossible for me to understand how
that could happen
but here's the other point that i think
is really important to make here
this does not disprove let's just say if
these reports are accurate
and there were law enforcement officers
on the scene
for
upwards of 90 minutes
waiting outside and not going in
does that disprove the good guy with a
gun as the left calls it the good guy
with a gun theory does it disprove that
well good guys with guns
uh they're not the solution here no it
doesn't it proves it
okay because if there are officers if
there are officers with guns outside not
going in
and we're all very upset about that as
we should be why are we upset about that
because we know that they could go in
with their guns and stop this
now if you don't think that good guys
with guns can even do anything anyway
that's gonna if you think that's not
gonna solve the problem then you have no
right to be upset at the uh at the
people that were
standing outside the school with their
guns not going in because according to
you they can't solve the problem anyway
only if you think and know obviously
that good guys with guns can solve these
kinds of problems
um or at least at a minimum greatly
mitigate the damage that is done in
these situations if you believe that
then of course you're going to be upset
because you know what they could have
done
this is this is the common theme here
right it's it's whether it's a good guy
with a gun or a bad guy with a gun
it comes down to the guy
and the choices that he makes
so right no one is saying
just putting
a gun into the hand of a good guy is
gonna that's all you have to do he has
to use it
and he also very importantly here has to
know how to use it and has to have the
proper training
but we're going the opposite direction
in our in our country right when you
when you defund the police you take
resources away that means you can have
less training
and um and the more that police are
villainized and the the the fewer people
who want to become police officers
standards get lowered
standards are getting lower for a lot of
reasons that being one of them
so you have people that are less fit for
the job they have less training
so no the gun in and of itself isn't
going to solve the problem any more than
the gun in and of itself creates the
problem
what you need are good guys with guns
that have proper training and are
willing to act that's what you need
and guess what if you have those things
then yes you can prevent a lot of these
things from happening in the first place
and when god forbid they do happen you
can greatly mitigate
the the carnage
but you need training you need funding
and you need people that are willing to
do what they're supposed to do
and as i said yesterday we sent the 40
billion dollars to uh
to
uh ukraine
and we send billions more to foreign
countries every single year
with that kind of money you know what
i think maybe you could
there's a lot of training and a lot of
uh equipping that could be done
with that kind of money
all right
beto o'rourke showed up at a press
conference yesterday press conference
was supposed to be the governor updating
people about the shooting um but beto
decided to use this press conference
about dead children to grandstand and
pull a political stunt to help his
campaign
we have a little bit of that footage
let's watch that
excuse me
excuse me
excuse me
[Music]
[Applause]
this is totally predictable when you sir
you're out of line
sir you're online i'm sure you are out
of line please leave this auditorium
i can't believe you're a sick
it would come to a deal like this to
make a political issue
[Music]
like you why don't you get out of here
[Music]
[Applause]
so that's beto just using uh
19 dead children as a stage
for a political stunt
and that of course is all that is
there's no obviously no excusing that
whatsoever
uh you want to get up and make your
point about governor abbott whatever
dumb point you have to make
well you can
bet o'rourke is very good at fighting
cameras he's not very good at much of
anything else but he can find cameras
get himself in front of cameras and so
you could have your own little press
conference
do whatever you want
but this was a press conference this was
not a political
rally or something like that this was a
press conference updating
people about this situation
and better work shows up and the
reporting is that no surprise here this
was all this was all planned and staged
ahead of time apparently this is even
this is even mainstream media reporting
surprisingly uh saying that he that it
he sent in people beto did ahead of time
to save a seat for him in the front row
and he'd want to go in first he didn't
want to be there you know there's like
15 minutes everybody's milling around
and getting set up and he didn't want to
be there because it would maybe tip
people off so he had he sent people in
to save him the seat and then he snuck
in there and then he did his little
routine
uh governor abbott after the fact
responded to this outburst and here's
what he said
there are there are family members
their family members
who are crying as we speak
their family members
whose hearts are broken
there's no words that anybody shouting
can come up here and do anything
to heal those broken hearts
we all
every texan
every american
has a responsibility
where we need to focus not on ourselves
and our agendas we need to focus on the
healing and hope
that we can provide to those who have
suffered
unconscionable damage to their lives and
loss of life
we need all texans
to in this one moment in time
put aside personal agendas think of
somebody other than ourselves think
about the people who are hurt
and help those who have been hurt
uh those are the nice thoughts but the
problem is that beto o'rourke is
incapable of thinking of anyone but
himself he's just totally incapable of
that
and this is uh we're being led by people
like this now we're not being led by
beto o'rourke because he keeps running
for office and losing
but we're being led by people like bet
o'rourke
that even when kids are killed in a mass
shooting he still cannot
it's just it's instinctive reaction how
can i use this
oh this is a this is what he's thinking
this is an opportunity for a publicity
stunt
they probably sit around sat around in a
room with people
talking about this
oh how can we use this what's how can we
use this for for pr what are what are
our pr opportunities here
and look i i know that it's so it's
cliche at this point to complain about
the politicization and the exploitation
of uh of tragedy but
just just because it's a cliche doesn't
mean it's not true in fact uh one of the
this is
it is because it is true this has become
a cliche
and yes
as long as politicians have existed
you've had politicians exploiting
tragedy but
when this is like
everybody leading the country in the
government when they're all like this
when they don't even seem to have
anywhere within them
the human
instinct
to
actually be upset and and sad and mourn
over lost life when they don't even have
that in them
and when your whole government is run by
people like this that's when it becomes
a major problem and speaking of which
barack obama speaking of people who are
totally empty inside here's what he
tweeted
and this i honest to god i saw this and
i just stared at it for a minute because
i thought this has got to be
this is so on the nose there's just
did he really tweet this this has got to
be some kind of photoshop some kind of
joke but it's not so barack obama
tweeted as we grieve the children of
vivaldi today we should take time to
recognize that two years have passed
since the murder of george floyd
under the knee of a police officer
his killing stays with us all to this
day especially those who loved him
uh i knew oh he continues in the
aftermath of his murder a new generation
of activists rose up to challenge their
anguish into organized action launching
a movement to raise awareness of blah
blah okay i don't give a damn
uh he's tying it into george floyd
because barack obama was upset i guess
yesterday was what the second
anniversary of george floyd's death and
people weren't talking about that so if
he wanted to find a way to loop it all
back around
hey i know you guys are mourning today
over
uh the fact that 20 children were killed
but remember george floyd that's what we
really should be talking about
okay george floyd was a violent criminal
lowlife
hopped up on fentanyl
who died while resisting arrest because
he was trying to pass counterfeit bills
and you're drawing any you're putting
him in the same sentence
as innocent children who are slaughtered
in mass at school
like these are comparable
in any way whatsoever
and after he tweeted this of course the
left is defending him and
uh i i started seeing these other
articles that have been written recently
there was one i think it was in the
atlantic i don't remember uh saying that
lamenting the fact that uh well george
floyd's memory is is fading we're all
forgetting about george floyd already
well first of all i wish but second why
shouldn't it fade
why should why should we remember his
death exactly no one's ever really
explained that
like lots of people die in this country
every single day
and there are certain people who are
worthy of being remembered and mourned
by the entire nation
and many of them are are not though but
there are certain people who are worthy
of that
all the children who were killed in the
mass shooting
yes remember and mourn them the entire
nation the entire world that's that's
that is a tragedy worthy
of of and and
which calls to be remembered and mourned
but george floyd just some criminal
scumbag
who
forced his way into a woman's home and
robbed her at gunpoint
and despite what we're told no he never
cleaned his life up but he cleaned his
life up but he died hopped up on
fentanyl trying to pass counterfeit
bills like that's how he cleaned his
life no it's just a she's a criminal
a man who was a was a predator
prayed on his own community
never contributed to anything worth
while this community only contributed
fear and
crime and violence to it
oh we're forgetting george floyd so
that would actually be a sign of
progress it is a sick society that
remembers that specially remembers and
mourns somebody like george floyd
and it's an even sicker society that
puts him on the same
level
and puts his death at the same level of
tragedy
as 20 kids who are killed
but this is all kind of it's like it's
like wishful thinking because in
actuality
uh george floyd is not being forgotten
and he's the one he still has his
monuments and uh and his streets named
after him and he's gonna have schools
named after him soon enough and he's got
the murals
no it's these kids who were killed um
they're the ones
outrageously tragically like
who end up getting forgotten almost
immediately
all right um
what else we got here so there's
a clip i wanted to play for you
uh i think we have time okay i'm just
gonna play this this is a leftist
teacher who i guess is a coach to young
kids some kind of coach
and uh she recorded herself
teaching the kids about her insane
pronoun nonsense
and i just want you to listen to a
little bit it's actually quite
instructive to hear this and she decided
to record it herself
and put it on tik-tok and let's listen
no matter what your gender identity is
you are okay exactly the way you are
and you are loved
it feels good to be yourself doesn't it
[Music]
the end goodness how did your girls like
this book
really good
what about you
i am like jj so i'm not a boy or a girl
so i have a question do you know what
you call
how do you refer to a girl you say she
right
you say she is funny
and when you're talking to a boy what do
you say
he
and what should you say if you're
talking to someone who is not a boy or a
girl do you know
you say they
so if you're saying she is funny for a
girl and you say he is funny for a boy
or somebody who's neither you can say
they are funny can you practice saying
that
they
are
funny so when you're talking about coach
carolee who is not a boy or a girl what
should you say where are you
exactly i'm not a boy or a girl so what
should you say instead of he or she
good job or they are my coach who are
you
i'm neither i am what the book calls
non-binary can you say non-binary
you're a boy and a girl and that's okay
right you're both
huh
yeah you can be both or you can be
neither
so once again yet another example they
keep they keep recording themselves
doing this and they they're so proud of
it and they put it online and they
of course have no self-awareness at all
which is the enduring irony with these
people because they're totally obsessed
with themselves and all they think about
is themselves but they also have no
awareness of themselves which is very
interesting uh there's something to be
said about that like the more that you
the more that you obsess over yourself
and think about yourself the less aware
of yourself you actually are but anyway
and they put this online and so they
don't realize that this just complete on
top of
they are telling on themselves and
revealing themselves to be groomers
and uh and they're showing off how
creepy and disgusting they are
it also undermines
their entire premise because you can
hear
the kids
they
audibly
have no idea what's being said to them
they're just repeating it
and then you hear one of these uh one of
these little kids in the background
says i'm a boy and a girl
and she latches on to that and affirms
it oh you're a boy and a girl yes
the kid is no way to just he's just
saying words like all little kids do
and if you were to
have a follow-up question and say what
do you mean by that how are you a boy
and a girl
it doesn't
know you wouldn't be able to explain it
of course because he's just a little kid
so even though we only heard the audio
we didn't see the the visual there you
could just imagine these kids just kind
of sitting there wide-eyed you know
sitting
uh indian style if i can still say that
on the carpet
looking up at the teacher wide eye just
kind of nodding their heads uh okay okay
no clue what's being said to them
and that's how the indoctrination always
works let's get now to the comment
section
mark says matt what are pixie stix
you got to be kidding me mark
don't
how old are you
do pixie stix not exist anymore
i think they still exist right
uh
this is this is you know this is kids
kids these days
when i was a kid this is the kind of
thing that we subsisted on pixie stix
and what what i would in fact do
is i would uh you know get an allowance
and my allowance was like i think it was
like five dollars uh it's like five
dollars a quarter you know
every several months i get five bucks
but i would save it up and then i would
go to uh like the drugstore and i'd get
candy and oftentimes they had these uh
pixie sticks that were the
there's the more normal pixie sticks
which were the size about a pencil and
all it was just sugar then we also had
these and i don't see these anymore okay
so kids don't know about these but it's
like these pixie sticks that were the
size of a rope like a jump rope
and it was just a tube full of sugar and
you would just chug those things
and that was uh that was allowed back in
the 90s back in the good old days
modern pappas says what um
or papist however you pronounce whatever
your preferred pronunciation is what the
shooter did was terrible but we aren't
to hope someone burns in hell even if
they are our enemy we're called to pray
for our enemies we should pray for these
souls that died including the shooter we
should pray for the families of those
that lost someone we should pray for the
kids that were traumatized god will
judge accordingly
yes you're correct i recognize the that
you're correct on an intellectual level
but
uh when you're dealing with i i guess
maybe unlike you i just don't have the
capacity
uh when i'm when i'm confronting evil at
that level
i'll fully admit i don't have the
capacity for mercy or forgiveness
with that kind of evil
uh david says when they say this is a
hill worth dying on they forget one key
element you're dying on that hill not
for it hills are defensible positions
from which you protect the entire land
by refusing to die on a hill you're
putting at risk everything which lies
behind it
that's a very good point i wish i had
thought of it
but thank you for that david
uh spencer says
what would be more of a nightmare for
you finding out that aliens do exist but
never meeting one in your lifetime or
not being able to grow a beard for the
rest of your life
uh well finding out the aliens exist but
we can't meet them is not a nightmare at
all
i actually the only thing i would make
you know i've often thought about
how that would affect people
because when you think about the you
know watch all the sci-fi movies and
everything it's usually aliens come here
and they land and how's how's that gonna
work
but um if we ever do become really aware
of of the existence of inalienate
civilization more than likely it'll come
in a way where it's it's we're not able
to actually make contact maybe some kind
of radio signal or something like that
um
and i've also thought about well how
would that would how would that affect
the world not not if aliens land here
but just if let's just say
hypothetically
we were to get 100 confirmation
undeniable confirmation that there is an
intelligent alien civilization out there
somewhere somewhere in another solar
system but we can't make but we can't
we'll never encounter them but we know
that they're there
how would that affect us
and the nightmare the depressing thing
is that of course as i've realized
especially over the last few weeks it
would not affect us at all but nobody
would care at all we would just go about
our lives
like it's like it doesn't matter um
and mike says matt's reaction to the
shooting is painfully predictable it's
simple usa both has more guns than any
other country and more mass shootings
as well the usa doesn't seem to take
care of its lost souls as well as other
countries do well mike i'm glad you
brought that up because that everything
you just said there is completely false
here's some exciting news the daily
wires in-house ad sales team in
nashville is expanding and we currently
have a number of openings that we're
working to fill on the team including a
client success manager digital sales
representative senior ad operations
manager and senior audio and digital
sales representative the daily wires ad
sales department is a crucial division
of the company that is responsible for
driving advertising revenue across daily
wires digital and audio platforms we're
excited to be building out this in-house
team with talented experienced and
passionate individuals who will help to
usher our partners into the next phase
of audio and digital advertising for
details on all of the positions
currently open on our ad sales team and
to apply visit dailywire.com careers a
full list of all the current openings in
daily wire can be viewed there as well
so head to dailywire.com careers today
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
it always feels like cheating to use a
clip from the view for the daily
cancellation but sometimes it's
unavoidable such as the case here where
a one minute exchange between the
squawking hands on the view serves as a
convenient rundown of all of the major
misnomers and false narratives that
we've been hearing over the past 24
hours
and this is the great and sacred purpose
of this show i think the public service
it provides it gives you a condensed
even more simplified summary of every
dumb thing the left is saying about any
given subject and that is certainly the
case here and i'll let whoopi take it
away listen that's the question
what are we doing because we're we're
why are we always at square one with
this and i swear to god if i see another
republican senator talk about their
heart being broken i'm gonna go punch
somebody and kind of thoughts i can't
take it in your thoughts and prayers if
your thoughts and prayers were really
with everybody you'd have done something
by now
it's not like anybody's not trying to
make this happen what the hell is going
on
i want them to stop gaslighting me also
stop saying it's not it's not guns that
kill people it's people that kill people
it's guns they kill people okay stop
saying the opposite stop saying that
mental illness is behind this there's
mental illness in every country in the
world and they don't have this problem
so stop gaslighting me on that one and
stop saying that you can have a good guy
stop a bad guy with a gun we have seen
in both of these shootings in the past
three weeks that a good guy tried and
could not do it so stop gaslighting us
that about sums it up again everything
you heard there is standard leftist
boilerplate uh we hear all this after
every mass shooting and we've heard it
all incessantly since the shooting in
texas so let's go through it first we
get the complaints about thoughts and
prayers you know forget about your
thoughts and prayers they say we need to
do something
but if you're religious as at least a
few of those women on the view claim to
be and as many of the people who
complain about thoughts and prayers
claim to be
then you should know that praying is
doing something it shouldn't be the only
thing you do you should do other things
along with praying but praying is
something
and the good thing is that nobody's ever
argued that all we should do is pray but
in the immediate moments after a
travesty like this
unless you're physically on the scene
and actively involved in that way there
may be nothing else you can do in that
moment at that exact time
but pray
okay like in the in the five minutes
after you hear about something like this
then it happened a thousand miles away
it's i wanna do something well
in that exact moment
for most people there's probably like
almost nothing you could do in those
five minutes but you can pray
and why shouldn't you it's a good thing
this is not an either or choice it's not
mutually exclusive praying doesn't
prevent you from taking physical action
so what exactly is the complaint here do
we really think that the problem in our
society is that we're praying too much
is that the source of our troubles
really
as for doing something what do you want
to do
the just do something mentality is a
scourge on our nation and on our body
politic
no we do not want our lawmakers simply
doing things
they already do a lot of things contrary
to popular beliefs they're not doing
nothing they're doing a lot of things
it's just that most of what they do is
ineffectual wasteful and often actively
harmful and counterproductive there's
nothing wrong with offering your prayers
after a mass shooting there is something
wrong with shouting into the void
somebody do something
that's a phrase that i would really like
to stop hearing
no problem is solved by doing something
problems are solved by doing particular
things
okay it's it's like if you have a flat
tire you're not gonna solve it just by
doing something there's a that's a a
particular problem very small problem
and it'll be solved in a certain
particular way
and that's true of every little small
problem you encounter in your life
you don't solve it just by just by
randomly taking action
you solve it by in targeted with
targeted action
and that's also true of the very big
problems in our society
and the reality is that the particular
things the gun control proponents want
to do
if you can even get them to propose any
particular things will not actually
prevent mass shootings and have not
prevented them as we discussed yesterday
a lot of these somethings have already
been put in place in many states and
cities across america and yet shootings
still occur and occur quite often
next we hear that it's not people who
kill people but guns and this is false
of course the inverse cliche doesn't
really work either in truth it's people
with guns who kill people but it's also
people without guns who kill people
people without guns kill people people
with guns kill people the common
denominator here is what
people
human choices human behavior kills
people
and so as we've been harping on we have
to get to the bottom of the human
behavior if we really want to make a
dent in this problem and finally and
here's the talking point i want to spend
some time with
we hear that this doesn't happen in
other countries
and i've heard this over and over and
over again since tuesday uh this doesn't
happen other countries they say we're
the only country this sort of thing
happens
what sort of thing and i suppose they
mean mass casualty attacks in fact the
onion on wednesday changed their home
page so that every headline on the whole
site says no way to prevent this says
only nation where this regularly happens
this is a very common claim united
states is unique across the entire world
in this respect the left says are they
right
no of course they aren't i mean not even
a little bit okay it's not even a little
right in fact just south of the border
this week
a guy in mexico shot up a whole a hotel
killing 11 people
that was this week okay this week
and yet we're told this only happens in
america
that's not even true this week
in fact mass casualty attacks happen all
the time in mexico and all across
central and south america they happen
quite famously in the middle east and
all over africa many parts of asia
indeed to make the claim that we're the
only country where this kind of thing
happens you must disregard from the
outset the vast majority of the globe
and the vast majority of the people
living on it
that seems like a rather important
qualifier that the person claiming we're
the only place where this happens should
mention they should stipulate by that by
when they say only place
when they
they mean the only place if you don't
count almost the entire world
of course the mass shootings in a place
like mexico mexico are often different
than they are here uh in the sense that
they're well they're the same in that
the victims
there still are victims who are being
killed
but the attacks in mexico are almost
always cartel related
if you go to somewhere like east africa
the terrorist group al-shabab is usually
responsible in other parts of the world
it's a different paracel or a different
crime network
and that's because young violent
hopeless nihilistic men in mexico are
likely to end up working for cartels in
east africa they're going to find
they're going to find al-shabaab as
their elder in america
they either end up joining street gangs
or they stay isolated in their mom's
basement until one day they explode
different manifestations but a similar
phenomenon this is the reason
by the way
why rankings of school shootings are
irrelevant you've perhaps seen that
wikipedia list floating around
showing that america has hundreds of
school shootings while afghanistan has
had only three
what they neglect to mention is
afghanistan also only has like three
people in school
there are lots of murders
lots of mass slaughter happening in that
country and in many of these other
countries that have very few school
shootings it just doesn't happen at
school very often
because school isn't a big part of their
culture
as we said different manifestations but
still the same sort of thing the same
sort of terrible thing
now i made this point on twitter
yesterday and i was immediately informed
that my argument isn't valid because
when people say
that we're the only place in the world
where this happens they really of course
just mean among western countries
that's a bit awkward isn't it
so what you're saying is that only the
predominantly white countries count
is that so when you say the entire world
you're actually just talking about the
white world
now i i don't agree with you that only
the white countries count only the
predominantly white countries count
but but let's just pretend that i do is
it true that we're the only country in
the western world where this happens
no in fact a ranking of annual death
rate per million from mass shootings in
north america and europe according to
world population review puts us at
number 11
behind czech republic belgium finland
switzerland slovakia albania macedonia
france serbia and norway
now you could point out that norway
makes the list in fact it tops the list
largely because of one major attack back
in 2011. that's true
but that's what happens when you measure
this on a per capita basis which you
have to because norway has 5 million
people and we have 330 million people
so if you're gonna compare us in the
number of people that are killed in mass
shootings the only fair way to do it is
per capita
if you're measuring like the number of
people who do anything
we're going to beat norway on every
measure for everything because we have
so many more people than them
so when you measure it by per capita
basis the united states does not really
stand out
in fact john lott with the crime
prevention research center published a
report about two years ago on this
subject and here's what it says in the
abstract it says the u.s is well below
the world average in terms of the number
of mass public shootings and the global
increase over time has become has been
much bigger than for the united states
over the 20 years from 1998 to 2017 our
list contains 2772 attacks and at least
5 764 shooters outside the united states
and 62 attacks on 66 years within our
country why our count the u.s makes up
less than
1.13 of the mass public shooters 1.77 of
their murders and 2.19 of their attacks
all these are much less than the us's
4.6 share of the world population
attacks in the us are not only less
frequent than other countries they are
also much less deadly on average out of
the 101 countries where we have
identified mass public shootings
occurring the united states ranks 66th
66th in the per capita frequency of
these attacks
and 56 in murder rate not only have
these attacks been much more common
outside the us the us's share of these
attacks has declined over time
and this is all the case
even though the u.s is unique in having
such a large and demographically mixed
population so what does this prove that
we don't have a problem
that we should do nothing to protect our
kids in school
obviously not
all it proves is that the narrative from
the left is false and the fact that it's
false is important
because the truth is important
so when they say we're the only country
where this happens that is not true on
any level by any measure no matter how
you're looking at it
and you cannot solve a problem by
misrepresenting it
but of course they're not trying to
solve the problem they're trying to
exploit it
that's an entirely different thing from
solving
it and that is why all of the people
pushing these false narratives not just
the women on the view though perhaps
especially them for this and many other
reasons
are canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
beta o'rourke turns a somber news
conference in a grieving community into
a petty campaign stunt barack obama and
joe biden exploit the shooting in texas
to bring attention to george floyd and
the un decries monkey pox coverage as
homophobic
and racist check it out on the michael
knowles show